peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu passer les noms et c'est méchant
[Musique]
allez on n'a pas le temps on est passé
on a du travail
savoie m'écouter carbonneau j'avais
déjeuné chez maxime j'ai rendez vous
avec le sous secrétaire d'état
l'équipement demandé à dupont du fort
qui me prépare les plants d'ambroisie 2
je passerai les prendre tout à l'heure
je veux démontrer invite mer au jour 2 5
il repart à 3h30 pour les états unis
compris à côté alors carbonneau a dû
d'ailleurs monsieur bré la victime
monsieur jeudi pour du fort voulez-vous
avoir l'obligeance de préparer les
plants d'ambroisie de monsieur le
directeur passera les prendre tout à
l'heure mais il me les avait demandé
pour demain maintenant il a dû changer
d'avis les grands hommes sont comme ça
je ne sais pas si les grands hommes sont
comme ça mais il ne doit pas être tous
aussi envers dames messieurs dépend du
fort même avec carbonneau
je vous prie de surveiller vos paroles
il est vrai que notre patron et exigeant
pointilleux mail mais en mer comme vous
dites non
ah bah non il obtient
alors oui un accident qui ça un
contremaître monsieur veut mon boulot on
commence à mon dieu et où est il
ah bon oui oui monsieur le directeur le
recevant en fin d'après-midi un accident
je suis bouleversée mois allez encore un
peu vite et bien après on se met au
travail parce que le patron il serait
pas quoi vous m'écoutez carbone nous je
mets des déchets maxime j'ai rendez vous
va bien
moi ça va mais le papa de thanh hà dinh
monsieur maman poule aussi un accident
encore mais comment il est tombé d'une
poutrelle sur un chantier c'est grave
non il a juste une épaule luxée
dis moi ce n'est pas la première fois
mais c'est vrai ya six mois il avait
déjà fait c'est un échafaudage finira
par celle de la chance l'abandonnent
voilà un sujet qui devrait intéresser
papa oui dit il il est chez maxim's un
déjeuner d'affaires
je suis d'ailleurs surpris ce qui te pas
encore à briser bon agir et prévenir
nadine tout à l'heure que son père a
encore joué les acrobates avec
ménagement au collet et justement
portable je te fait cette recommandation
bon bah ouais elle n'a pas voulu monter
peur de croiser papa dans un couloir
les bons mots pour l'os voiture il est
retourné sur son chantier mais bien voir
tempère cet après-midi pour coiffeur
sans doute protester comme il l'a déjà
fait contre les systèmes de sécurité
qu'ils jugent insuffisants et inefficace
mais c'est une réunion de famille le
moment ou jamais vu demander sa fille à
papa sa bénédiction annoncé pas joué si
jamais vous regarde la carte du ciel
aujourd'hui à nu cette entrée dans le
scorpion et contrarie les projets de la
vierge mais projet de la bière et la
vierge je sais papa il est né en
septembre fait tu sais que quand quelque
chose contre henri tempère il part à
prendre avec des pincettes peut pas être
plus agressif que d'habitude je connais
les no
l'âge l'après-midi bam a flanqué à la
porte ça fera jamais que la 20e fois on
a trente deuxième jeu les cons à jour je
les ai pris au mot et je suis pas revenu
le lendemain j étais dans une colère
vient nous chercher jusque chez moi j'ai
cru qu'il allait me bats je sais tu me
le dis j'ai raconté dix fois mais allez
allez avoue que tant des fier et satee
mousty l'idée d'être battu par un
bâtiment elle raconte lui d'horreur
sinon mettait que j'ai déjà du mal à
passer l'épongé sur ce qui se passe en
premier c'est très bien ce qui se passe
entre nadine et moi jouent pas les
hypocrites team feels quand même temps
douce la clé de l'appartement témoin
pour que nous allions dans le calme le
réviser nos cours de droit
oui mais toi t'as jamais été amoureuse
j'ai failli te mets d'ailleurs je
travaille auprès de ton père depuis plus
de vingt ans alors maintenant je suis
trop mais avant ça j'étais trop jeune
ben moi j'ai juste la juge ait pas de
temps à perdre mais tu ne parlera pas
aujourd'hui parce que la lune deux jours
à nantes je me fous la lutte en temps la
dernière fois c'était saturn qui venait
d'entrer dans je ne sais plus quoi alors
la lune passera où elle voudra ça m'est
complètement égal
moi je passe dans l'offensive n'en sois
raisonnable a dit frédéric et mon père
il est raisonnable et tentait je ne dois
pas le juger bien entendu n'est pas à
moi de trouver bizarre ces notes de
service interdisant un secrétaire de
porter du jaune ou un vendeur sortir le
mardi en fait c'est quoi de nouveau
démenti fm ici pas moi et je suis pas
son employé je suis parle pas
aujourd'hui demain il aura croisé un
chat noir et après me rêvais d'un
serpent écoute je t'assure que nous
trouverons un moment favorable aux
ordres de la destinée je sais depuis mon
enfance temps d'en parler que de chances
de superstition de signes du zodiaque
c'est un malade n'empoisonnent sa vie et
celle des autres
faudrait faire désintoxiquer bon tu vas
me faire croire que tu marches dans
toutes ces histoires je ne sais pas
depuis 20 ans que je vis avec ça c'est
devenu une seconde nature
je suis peut-être pas croyante mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que je suis pratiquant
puis tu dira tout ce que tu voudras
tempéra quand même réussi il est le
premier promoteur immobilier de france
et il est le seul promoteur constructeur
pas étonnant il a un bol terrible
sauf en amour j'aurais quand même bien
voulu être là le jour où il a appris
comment ces tirs avec un taureau robin
ah ben voilà pourquoi il aime pas le
jour de l'an ce qui peut bien faire je
commence à m'inquiéter tu devrais être
habitué aux déjeuners d'affaires de
papin la vente illégale américaine
ça rassure toi j'entends son joyeux la
ville
à l'accident stupide je me suis cassé la
figure au restaurant du petit budget ses
citoyennes vous étiez chez maxi mêlant
le déjeuner a été décommandé au dernier
moment j'ai été très contrarié alors
j'étais au restaurant du petit but il
avait pris ses battements message en
était sûrs depuis ce matin si je n'avais
pas été au restaurant du petit budget je
ne me serais pas casser la figure dans
l'escalier en chèvre il n'avait rien de
cassé le poignet d'amy c'était écrit
c'était écrit à douala nous sommes le 18
du 18 au 23 lune en scorpion suspicion
et titouan carbonneau vous n'avez jamais
rêvé comme moi cette nuit d'une oreille
piqué par une épingle à nourrice a même
sur les toits
non mais je suis encore jeune mais
qu'est ce que tu viens faire mais
j'avais pensé qu' il avait pensé alors
ça c'est nouveau
quoi de neuf mais à l'accident monsieur
je vais vous le dire non pas le vôtre
monsieur celui d'al de vous contremaître
messieurs va mon boulot s'il est tombé
d'une poutrelle sur le chantier bourgade
mille ariane cassé lui non plus qui s
est un des films comme on veut tout dire
ça c'est celui qui est déjà tombé il ya
six mois juste le jour vous vous êtes
fait une entorse il ya vous voir tout à
l'heure elle veut pas voir le la porte
11 juillet c'est une excellente idée je
vais le mettre à la porte mais il est
retourné sur son chantier seul homme
courageux
il va me porter la scoumoune qu'il avait
cassé la figure ailleurs que chez moi
préparer l'émission chèque de
licenciement je ne vais pas voir c'est
un maladroit c'est un grec de da qu'ils
aillent se faire par ailleurs
tu peux tout de même pas balancer un
homme qui vient de tomber parce que tu
m'as envoyé sur un chantier se casser la
figure dit tout de suite que c'est moi
qui les poussait pas de danger pourquoi
du monde jamais là où exactement il ya
des gens qui ont le mauvais oeil qui
sont des portes ging et c'est contagieux
c'est contagieux parfaitement c'est
contagieux tu as raison papa c'est
contagieux
j'ai toujours raison je suis venu l anah
jean-claude c'est moi qui vais déjà chez
les plantes à l'inami us quelle journée
m'ont dit qu'elles j'en étais sûr ce
matin en ouvrant la fenêtre j'ai vu un
oiseau arrivée par la gauche rend compte
non tu te rends pas compte c'est grave
ça si c'est grave je pense qu'il en fait
je suis bien content de te voir
on ne saura jamais été rarement là les
heures de liberté que tu octroie la
faculté de droit semble ne pas coïncider
avec mes rares moments de détente à
venir c'est à dire rien du tout bon
j'aime pas ça tombe bien moi aussi mais
toi ça n'a aucune importance
moi ce que j'ai à te dire est très
important seulement voilà ne m'en
souviens plus ah si
qu'est ce que tu fais le week-end le
prochain rien bon parfum je t'emmène en
sologne à la chasse avec moi à cesser la
battue me parlera ne fait pas la vessie
c'est ici que j'te pas j'ai été invité
par pilette pineta m'épiler times le
groupe il est à l'entrepreneur leroy
dubé tant pis l'état avec lequel je
traite de très grosses affaires lafreux
pile est un non monsieur pierre tu as
besoin de moi pour aller tirer des
petites bêtes chinois du béton c'est
mieux que je suis incapable de dire et
quoi que ce soit d'ailleurs il connaît
de confirmer pas un fusil veut me
confier quelque chose de plus délicat
billets non j'invoque temps joue
vraiment pas en quoi je pourrais être
utile dans tes affaires et ce ne sont
pas mes affaires elles peuvent être les
tiennes tillet mes affaires mais nous
voulons pas continuer à jouer aux
devinettes jusqu'à demain matin
et puis il faut que je file au genre je
sais tu connais la situation de
l'affreux pilote de monsieur pilote à sa
situation est énorme en réel de filles
qui étaient normaux ce qu'ils étaient
il a une fille unique et elle tu ne la
connais pas et alors et alors moi j'ai
un fils unique et lui tu le connais
c'est toi alors fils unique fille ni
pilette avignon vignon piles et à
rencontres comme ça j'ai pas l'intention
de me marier mais nous n'en sommes
qu'aux prémices
alors je demande pardon je la connais la
fif il est un tweet était venu ici l'an
dernier faire un rapport pour son
concours de sortie de la chaussée est
bien passé et je ne m'en souviens pas en
jouant souvient elle m'avait frappé de
lui avait manqué de respect à ce point
là
[Musique]
mais lol v fera puis je l'avais remarqué
et bien c'est tout le portrait de son
père oui non sans blague
oui oui même le nez un peu plus fort et
être un bruit alors pas de montholon et
avant la bouche de travers mais les
myopes commune taux bas comme ça tu
pourras vieillir s'engage sur la
perçoivent quelle boîte
seulement quand elle marche
il avait qu'a adopté une vie sédentaire
pour le reste je m'en souviens pas où
ils étaient tellement dix trains laisse
moi te dire que tu me proposera un drôle
de cadeau il y à la chirurgie esthétique
avec elle on arrive à tour sur la côte
est on leur coupe
si vous en manche le rajoute puis dans
la vie y'a pas que la beauté physique ya
les 15e et leurs frais les qualités mais
avec quelles chaussures pas de cocu
c'est déjà ça non je ne voulais pas te
rebattre les oreilles avec des lieux
communs il y a plus sérieux tu es
jupitérien ascendant sagittaire et la
bétonneuse elle est quoi l et boiteuse
mais non elle et balance ascendant lion
oui moi je peux faire et qu'elle soit
n'importe quoi avec le physique de marie
les yeux cette rencontre est rarissime
vous donnez astral sont fabuleusement
complémentaire des cordes elle est
semblable ou l'entente une fois par
siècle
et encore heureusement et se tatouant ya
le soleil qui vous apportera l'harmonie
l'épanouissement dans votre vie
sentimentale et marche tu te rendras
actifs vie rime et qui te dans l'appétit
de vivre
ah bah tant mieux parce que l'homme
l'appétit mot faudrait si je faisais la
fille des teintures nord a de l'appétit
boulot tu me rappelles agamemnon lagat
coin agamemnon a mis le barbu qui
s'avance justement c'était un roi qui
n'a pas hésité une molle et sa fille
pour obtenir la protection des dieux et
un vent favorable n'a rien à voir non tu
veux mi-mollet parce que ça arrange les
affaires
l'alliance de la part-dieu béton du roi
de l'immobilier tu viens samedi prochain
avec moi et puis choix gracieux je dois
signer avec le pire des contrats
extrêmement teint tour normes
geoffrey ton bonheur malgré toi là je
pleure monsieur monsieur dupont du fort
n'a pas eu le temps évidemment mais
c'est un imbécile carbonneau matin
maintenant oui ma patte de lapin alors
axial croque solaire inch'allah moustaph
guider l'homme à manama bahreïn il se
raccorde
d'arbonneau que walsh sur le bureau d'un
couple à pierre jeantet c'est un signe
du bélier dans mon cas signe de bélier
signes de danger étrangers moi ça ne
l'est pas c'est un cadeau de la banque
je n'ai pas réussi à l'apprivoiser c'est
pas super physio de sa portman tarnos
qu'est ce que j'ai à vous dire je ne
sais pas si vous savez rien qu'à m'en
confesser ce petit il un grand secret
vous offrir la renault ouvre vraiment
mais il ya peu d'initiatives
je suis un film n'est pas pitié pour les
infirmes 1 vous marcherez sur un aveugle
[Applaudissements]
qu'un secret quel secret s'est mis dans
la tête de me coller la fille pilotes
mondiaux qu'alors que je peux pas dire
si nous avions pas parlé non non mais
j'ai mieux à une idée qui fait son
chemin c'est lui qui va découvrir nadine
et me l'imposé pas je voudrais bien
savoir comment tu vas savoir tu vas
savoir et tu va m'aider madeleine
madeleine je t'adore et nadine à la
ah ben je vous adore toutes les deux
pour un usage différent
après quand elle n'est pas là je sais je
l'entends dû partir c'est pourquoi je me
suis permis de monter vous avez bien
fait d'ailleurs il vous mangerez pas
envie d'un solide appétit mais dont je
serai là tout ne risquera rien mon bébé
asseyez vous demandez mais bon je dois
vous dire que votre papa va venir voir
monsieur vignon cet après midi mon père
ici mais pourquoi flèche il s'était
encore blessés syriens rassurez-vous
commence à retomber aux mondieux mais
qu'est-ce qu'il n'a rien lui la juste
une épaule luxée rohff papa ou ça
m'étonne pas pourquoi ils étaient très
préoccupés ce matin en partant son
travail a figuré vous qui devait
déjeuner à midi avec une vieille tante
du côté de maman à laquelle ils devaient
emprunter de l'argent pour acheter un
appartement
la vieille gare s'est décommandé sous
prétexte des runes et papa cru voir là
un moyen pour ce défilé
il en a été très contrarié et quand
quelque chose le contrarie il y pense
toute la journée n'est plus attentifs à
ce qui fait alors quand on sent
madeleine un déjeuner décommandé et à la
le parallélisme qui continue qu'est ce
que tu veux dire
qui n'a pas remarqué cette coïncidence
extraordinaire ton père est bien les
deux accidents le même jour à non
partants on a souvent parlé des des
jumeaux désastre et la wii astro jeunes
à attacher d'importance à ces
divagations mais pour une fois j'y suis
s'il est acquis même s'il a dit mme
nadine la date de naissance de ton père
7 septembre 1922 fantastique
ils sont du même signe celui de la
vierge les deux bières c'est beaucoup
plus inouï que ça tu connais pas la date
de naissance de tempête je sais que
c'est en septembre 7 septembre 1922
incroyable mais vrai ils sont nés le
même jour mais c'est plus que je n'en
espérais dis-moi dis-moi madeleine t'as
pas lu les bouquins là dessus ah non je
sais que les jumeaux désastre en
beaucoup intrigué les astrologues ton
père aussi en particulier mais je
connais aucune théorie là-dessus bon
alors c'est bien simple nous allons en
inventer une qui croient que tempère va
avaler ça il digérait sait bien qu'il
est prêt à vendre à n'importe quelle âme
son nom mais cette fois ci nous allons
lui servir
exclusivité nous allons imaginer une
théorie nouvelle qui dit que toute chose
dans le monde 1 sont parallèles ah oui
lorsqu'un enfant naît il naît en même
temps un autre enfant qui est son double
comme un jumeau
même s'il est né à l'autre bout de la
terre et et et nous ajouterons plus tard
qu'une union n'est de leur enfant ne
peut être extrêmement bénéfique
les statistiques disent qu'il n'est dans
le monde 15 enfin la même seconde
oui oui mais comme il n'est pas question
de présenter un chinois polynésiens ou
avec hannibal comme son double il va se
jeter sur père de nadine mais oui bon
alors dit moi c'est moi quelque chose
sur ton père un un trait particulier une
singularité physique
une originalité quelconque il a un grain
de beauté sur le sein gauche
papa aussi hommes mais pas cet endroit
je pense pas un qui dit gigi jamais vu
tempère devenir un toutou fait bouillir
allez-vous-en les amoureux c'est plus
prudent
les amoureux ont quelque chose à te
demander encore là qu'est d'aller vous
ruiner la santé
cette série jamais enfin apercevrait tu
es comment fait pas encore visité la
muse appartement témoin d'un garnement
au celui de la rue de ménilmontant non
préfère celui de l'avenue foch et puis
quoi encore c'est tout dans celui de la
rue de ménilmontant ya pas de matelas
sur le sommier aux non c'est pas
tellement pour moi que je te demande
saas et c'est surtout pour nadine c'est
pas confortable mais toi sa place il
n'en est pas question
et rapporte la moelle demain matin s'en
faut mesurer
merci m lire via ma chérie ça me fait
encore plus plaisir à moi qu'à vous ce
serviteur prix fort
vous n'avez pas vu oui mais non je veux
des gens ont valu prenez ça fait en
faire des photocopies
envoyez-le à new york et dit à cet
imbécile de dupont du fort que je lui
interdit de tirer des épreuves en jouant
au chat qui s'était nos couleurs
maléfique dont le papa c'est moi
pour une fois je te parle un petit
moment où elle seule minute tu dois
recevoir le cascadeur gré c'est
précisément à son sujet que je vais te
parler
si c'est pour prendre sa défense c'est
inutile c'est dans ton intérêt internet
dis moi tu n'as pas été frappé par la
similitude de vos deux accidents non bon
bon c'est pas tout rappelle qu il ya six
mois il est arrivé à notre pépin à
chacun de vous au même instant est vrai
autre coïncidence
tu sais pourquoi il est tombé manara
mais non il était contrarié mais
pourquoi un déjeuner important
décommandé au dernier moment comme moi
comme toi et c'est pas fini
attend la suite tu n es oui benata date
de naissance papa ah oui 7 septembre
je ne te le fais pas dire frappés par
ces curieuses coïncidences j'ai demandé
à madeleine de consulter les fiches du
personnel tu ne vas pas me dire que si
non oui achille 20 mo pou l'os est né le
5 septembre 922 à à quelle heure itunes
et 22h10 lui aussi cet incroyable mais
vrai si la théorie du professeur
albrecht se vérifie vous êtes les
jumeaux désastre
le professeur guy assez pauvre tu
connais pas le professeur albrecht tu
connais black professeur albrecht
provinciaux rolls royce en non le
professeur albrecht était un célèbre
psychiatre berlinois le grand ami de
freud au le professeur
non mais tu prononces et mal rafraîchir
un peu la mémoire et il affirmé que
parmi tous les hommes nés le même jour
de la même année à la même heure il y en
a 2 dont les existants sont
inexorablement ligne
ils peuvent avoir des destinées
différentes mais mais leur vie seront
parallèle marquée par des événements
similaires ayant le même terme c'est la
théorie du professeur un break à brecht
dit aussi théorie du double et aurait dû
doubler vos vies sont liés pour le
meilleur comme pour le pire
s'il prend froid tu peux t'en remets mon
dieu il faut que tu veilles sur lui
comme sur toi même
car vous mourrez le même jour les
moquées d'elle foot à la porte
alors est ce que tu es venu pour
m'ouvrir les sk comment ça fait tilt
déjà une brèche dont l'autre les
cascadeurs de la chiffa vos poules hawks
h il va beaucoup l'os
je veux connaître cette d'achille va
nous plonge je le vois la tête qu'à mon
jumeau ou et il paye travail d'après ce
que m'a dit madeleine sur le chantier
google annonçait dans un assaut on veut
voir 10 y aller non protégés une aile
oui c'est une bonne idée et tu regardes
là haut à gauche oui mais c'est vrai je
vois ma vie mais ces travaux mais c'est
très dangereux mais je n'utilise kulula
alors tout ça le fait descendre
immédiatement le contremaître le grand
stade le un contremaître à chaud dans
mon pool hausse et qu'il me rejoindre le
plus vite possible avant bureau ou
plutôt non qu'il prenne son temps pas
d'imprudence dire que je risquais ma vie
tous les jours et que je le savais mais
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour la
développer il descend pas ebe à siby
voilà sanaa dans quelques instants à mon
petit ce jour est un proche grâce à mon
fils j'ai trouvé mon frère tombé du ciel
qui aurait pu tomber pour de bon surtout
qu'ils ignorent toujours nos liens de
parenté pourquoi ça me regarde je suis
tout ému c'est beau hein je suis
doublement satisfait je constate que mon
enseignement a porté ses fruits
et tu le fais pas fi de ces signes du
destin qui ont une importance si
considérable dans notre existence
si j'avais l'air de pas m'y intéresse
mais mais dans le fond j'étais passionné
tu cachait bien son jeu comme au poker
désormais nous pourrons parler tous les
deux de ses grands problèmes
tout ça oui ça y est là ok c'est lui si
tu t'es mu
si jamais une vraie personne dans ma
famille n'a jamais failli à six mois
seul à l'ailé ce match tu profites tu
sais mon frère andré je vous en prie je
vous attendais
vous tombez bien
le directeur m la plaisanterie alors je
veux dire vous arrivez bien ça aussi
c'est une blague bien sûr que non après
je vous en prie a cédé c'est pas la
peine je vais pas vous déranger
longtemps jamais en fait je suis bien
content de pouvoir
mon ami wally ou un higuain je ne suis
pas votre ami et je ne fume pas le
cigare à cette heure ci et puis faites
bien attention de pas avalé le vôtre
parce que ce que j'ai à vous dire va pas
vous faire plaisir
qu'est ce qui ne va pas cet après midi
j'ai failli me tuer en tombant d'une
poutrelle à cause d'un pays si on
arrivera ici j'apprends vous une fiche à
la porte et vous me demandez ce qui va
pas qui parle de vous mettre à la porte
rousselet votre chef du personnel ordre
de la direction et manifs on comptait
près qu'elle investissait tuyaux n'a
rien compris je lui avais dit que je
voulais vous remercier
il aura traduit quand j'étais au
contraire même connaître et vous serrer
la main
c'est autre chose puisque j'ai moins
rien de cassé nos héros moi non plus je
n'ai pas voulu être en reste avec vous
c'est sûrement pas sur un de vos
chantiers que vous vous êtes fait c'est
exact mais le résultat est là parce qu'à
une chose que je voulais voudrions je
sais le système de sécurité mais je vais
donner des instructions sans plus tarder
le système de sécurité je ne tiens pas
comme certains de mes collègues à me
retrouver en taule pour dans quelques
années si vous avez écouté il ya six
mois je n'aurai pas de poignée d'ennemis
vous voulez dire que j'aurais pas les
pots le luxe et c'est la même chose
n'est pas facile à comprendre ça ne
cherchez pas en tout cas ce que je
comprends c'est que votre question m'a
donné mon compte
on s'attend bien parce que moi je vais
vous donner ma démission vous attendent
ici
n'y pensez pas j'ai pensé qu'appeler mon
premier accident ma chute aujourd'hui
c'est la goutte d'eau
je pense ville finir mes jours dans une
poussette le poussette mais moi non plus
monsieur mambé boulos à vous c'est votre
affaire et vous risquez pas grand chose
je risque autant que vous décidément
vous aimez bien rigolé déteste pas la
présence en ce moment j'en ai guère
enneigées de la famille moi j'ai une
femme une enfant qui fait des études
mais moi aussi monsieur va mon boulot
j'ai un enfant début des études alors
vous me comprenez y écouter non
n'insistez pas prendre une encoche
démissionne je m'en vais oui et vous
dans une entreprise on aura de la
considération pour les ouvriers ça
existe ça
en cherchant bien au moins j'en
trouverai bien une qui respectent les
normes de sécurité
j'aurais pas de mal à me recaser avec
mes états tient aux comores mais ils
sont ils sont excellents vous êtes un de
mes plus vieux compagnons quinze maisons
messieurs direct quinze maisons
conscience que honnête travailleur et
puis vous avez risqué deux fois votre
vie à cause de moi raconte salah béchir
c'est la même chose et vous pensez que
je me sépare épouse depuis jusqu'à celle
là tu veux mon nom de trophée exprès
puis pour divorcer il faut être deux
votre démission de repli je raisonne ses
yeux d'abord j'ai dû faire descendre
deux bouts échafaudages pour ça j'ai pas
besoin de vous
oui en effet j'ai besoin d'un chef de
bureau je vais vous prendre dans des
bureaux pour quoi faire
je ne sais pas mais je trouverais non
mais vous me voyez chef de bureau
ma place sur l'échantillon la hausse fut
un grand terre dans un bureau et tout va
bien je préfère que vous étouffe tu es
en bas dans un bureau plutôt que de vous
savoir en eau sur une poutre elle
n'aurait pas toujours une plateforme
pour amortir votre chute je voterai 80 m
plus pas complètement zappé petit
bonhomme en mousse râle étage dans un
bureau avec une grande baie dont la
vitre est cassée
nous ne la ferons pas réparer comme ça
toute la journée pour espérer le grand t
on tant que vous voulez ah oui peut-être
comme ça mais j'aime bien mon métier
c'est tout à votre honneur je suis
consciencieux c'est ce qui me fait peur
vous êtes déjà tombé deux fois
jamais deux sans trois vous comptez trop
sur votre chance il ne faut pas la
provoquer si vous arrivez quoi que ce
soit j'aurais ça sur la conscience
vous ne pensez pas à moi vous ne pensez
pas suffisamment tampa c'est pas une
idée qui me serait venu j'ai un coeur
moi à mon boulot ce oui j'ai un coeur et
j'ai le vertige
alors si je devais requises vous risquez
de tomber
ça non plus ce n'est pas facile à
caumont prochains mois c'est pourtant
simple
je suis le patron si je m'écroule tout
mon entreprise s'écroule et tout le
personnel est sur le pavé une mais voilà
quinze ans que vous ne payez pour faire
ce travail
elle va vous payer beaucoup plus cher
pour être dans un bureau j'ai besoin de
vous moi van gogh ou l'os quel âge
avez-vous 54 54 ans vous allez continuer
dans la paix comme un jeune homme mange
en remontrerait encore un prix d'argent
facile mais une autre carrière vous
attend à mon âge vous voulez que je n'en
cycle mais voulait même vraiment pu la
signer notre vie la mienne et avant la
mort et à la retraite
vous serez cadre vous n'avez jamais
entendu parler de la retraite des cadres
à 60 ans bien doigt 55
ça ne vous dit rien la retraite des
cadres vous parler sérieusement j'en ai
parlé c'est ce qui m'étonne alors
vraiment colosse et oui on avait dit que
j'étais un peu maniaque mais tout de
même
alors c'est oui oui mais mon enveloppe
forge ou la robe débardeur à une
gratification soit une prime de chute ya
bien les ruines de transport ça ce
serait une peine de chute
alors c'est tout on n'en sait pas tout
je vais vous proposer pour la médaille
du travail et vous donner six jours de
repos pour vous remettre de vos émotions
et à dans le temps d'installer votre
nouveau bureau à ben qui va être
contente c'est ma femme elle était comme
vous l aimez pas promeut va faire le
guignol en place la régie pas dessus oui
mais c'est naturel tandis que vous nous
n'avons pas les mêmes raisons mais nous
n'aimerions dylan et l'autre vous perdre
je tiens à vous ou à belle dame aux
colosses ça vous a pris comme ça tout
d'un coup annonce à dijon depuis
longtemps je veux dire je me demande si
ma chute n'est pas plus grave
vous souffrez non mais je ne vois que
deux explications tout ce qui marche ou
je nage en plein comme je vais me
réveiller dans une salle de ce taux bien
sûr votre respect monsieur directeur ses
voûtes est tombé sur la tête
vous êtes bien d'éveiller je suis tombé
sur les dernières j'essaie de me
rattraper
et puis quand mettra sur et maintenant
ah non j'ai du mal à y croire
enfin tout bien réfléchi dans un bureau
chaussec ma jambe me fait souffrir quand
le temps est à la pluie
votre genre je suis tombé deux
mobylettes l'année dernière et a fait ça
vous dire par temps humide ses débuts
mais mon visage
moi même à la même jambe j'ai un
rhumatisme qui me tracasse depuis un
certain temps ça fait souffrir chez
alors une menace à part d'audience
écoutez vous allez rentrer chez vous
mais auparavant nous allons trinquer à
votre promotion
alors merci sans façon je tiens pas
d'alcool dès que je pourrai inverse je
suis bleury quelle coïncidence
moi non plus je ne suis pas l'alcool dès
que je prends un verre je suis enfin
comme vous dites allait rentrer c'est
vous et surtout pas d'un truc bien ces
chefs des recteurs obama dit dans ces
rigolos j'aurais préféré prendre votre
serviette
avez-vous quoi à cause des initiales en
v et sont les miennes alexandre vignon
avait mais ça fait aussi
achille webo photo h il va mot pelosse
alexandre vigneault à v nous avons les
mêmes initiales qui je pense va vous
faire le plus gros pays voici une
superbe chaîne avec une médaille de la
vierge
avant le maire annonça c'est la vierge à
la bonne mère soit pas une autre 1
maintenant vous ne risquez plus rien
vous pouvez la protéger on verra c'est
pas mon boss en fait arrivé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bell a oui papa est transformée depuis
je fais découvrir son frère astral ça
marche comme sur des roulettes d'être
aussi sûres que toi je passe mon temps à
essayer de rattraper les bêtises devant
mon boulot ce depuis que ton père l'a
nommé chef du service des ventes il
accumule les gaffes et maladroite non
des détails non ce qui compte c'est que
c'est que par faso dans d'excellentes
dispositions je puisse enfin lui
présenter nadine rien ne presse est ce
qu'il faut c'est multiplier les
coïncidences
c'est là que j'ai besoin de toi et moi
toi figure toi qui reçoit papa papa l'a
emmené dîner au restaurant oui il était
intarissable au dessert il allume cigare
il se voue le dos à grand monde savait
qu'il n'avait pas lu passer chez un
pharmacien pour lui faire un pansement
et à te fait rire mais non c'est la
suite qui me fait rire en voyant si
c'est drôle
voilà tu vas demander à 20 mo pou l'os
de venir te voir sous un prétexte
quelconque plus offrira un des cigares
de papa tu es lumeras et mine de rien
dans la conversation
tu lui brûle un peu le doigt tu es fou
frédéric
mais juste un peu qu'il puisse dire
qu'il s'est brûlé en allumant un cigare
à masquer tu te rends compte que tu me
demandes
bah oui sur des choses qui arrivent tous
les jours jamais mullen jamais merci ma
chérie je pouvais compter sur toi alors
dis-moi dix mots je t'appelle dans mon
boulot c'est en partant fige suite il
monte et c'est bien attention vas y
mollo s'agit pas de transformer en
bronze en quoi en bronze en torche
vivante
frédéric non là
tu peux pas le laisser tout seul ce
petit camp m osama jamais être clair je
vais demander à l'ue m
et petit ça le pende les grandes options
sait jamais
acheter un petit pansement
à
qu'est ce qu'il a dit un poids il a dit
un bond
mettre la dernière il le voyait
impressionnerait et bat outillés jeu
madeleine bref est appelé
vous êtes illégaux messieurs manon
pouliot jument voilà quand on est rendu
au maghreb appelez-moi h il a su
respecter la hiérarchie
non mais je reste très simple vous savez
je peux prendre des airs avec vous je
prétexte que je voterai modestie ross
votre mairie essayez vous immergez vous
êtes bien assis
vous n'êtes pas pressé y'a pas le feu
allez vas-y à cigares mon brave and
merci je ne fumerai ce soir à tribut
un statut spécial à signaler jeune hervé
pages et un briquet
thiam a pas ce qui m'a pris je voulais
vous demander vous vous êtes vraiment
grecque
oui mon grain pourquoi ça va je n'ai pas
du tout les grecs comme ça avant mais
comment vous les imaginez je ne sais pas
depuis que vous êtes là je suis observe
et je fige et je trouve que vous ne nous
avez pas nourri le profil conforme aux
canons de la plastique antique harry
travail mais j'aimerais manger pas un
profil de médaille mais je tiens de ma
mère elle était de connerré de connerré
dans la sarthe assez dallas mais deux
faces c'est mon père une phase de break
attendez je vais me rapprocher un petit
peu parce que je suis myope
oui maintenant que vous me le dites si
vous êtes mais venir pour servette et
xamax qui marche pas du tout
[Musique]
le patron du team a téléphoné bon ben ça
tombe bien parce que justement moi je
voulais vous parler ah bon je vous
écoute monsieur chinois grande du feu
lorsque ryan
il s'est excusé moi je suis doublement
la crasse épouvantable c'est rien j'en
ai vu d'autres tu montais hommes qui
pensent que les consignes données à 6 7
à 7 à 10 pense que l'infection
pratique donc vous êtes drôlement
organisé bâlois
d'accord on a un petit bouton après aval
un plus grand qui après pour vous coupe
le doigt levé la main ça fait mal à
suivre ambulance une pré qui
ils ont choisi une petite boucle fait
parce que ça fait quand même prévoir
c'est guérir
madeleine initiale s'était penché là
tu déjà les débats mais j'ai pas grave
quand vous en faire je vous prie de
m'excuser je suis tellement distraire
durée
mais je vais vous expliquer c'est pas
tout à fait figurez vous que j'ai
toujours cette carte du ciel
perpétuellement sous les yeux est trop
chargé alors je suis comme vous qui dure
est un peu dans la lune mais ça va
vous savez qu'il existe des cours de
formation permanente de salon gratuit
quand tu fasses la voilà
ça complète ça ça me rappelle mon jeune
temps quand j'étais nourrisson peut
toujours servir indien allah vous
vouliez me demander quelque chose dessus
achille
- ah bah oui oui oui vous n'êtes pas
étonné que je sois devenu du jour au
lendemain chef du service des ventes
je n'ai aucune compétence pour occuper
ce poste a toujours votre modestie
narines étroite signe de modestie
nordine moussa va se loger mais c'est
vrai je suis d'origine modeste
j'avais un salaire modeste à train de
vie modeste on ne se défait pas comme ça
de modestes d'habitude vous vous
habituerez très dit je suis très
heureuse pour vous de cette nomination
merci ses présences ou alors vous qui
connaissez bien le patron vous trouvez
pas ça bizarre tu vois pas ce qu'il y'a
bizarre je donne trois fois plus ah bah
c'est normal vous etc c'est bien un
poste supérieur charme tout ça vous
semble naturel
c'est une juste récompense a alors je
vous le demande
qu'est ce que j'ai fait vous avez 15 ans
de bons et loyaux services je trouvais
que ça mais rien n'est sûr j'ai pas dit
ça nommé chef du service des ventes il
ya dix jours j'étais contre m c'est une
belle promotion annoncée point de
promotion c'est une escalade en direct
pour moi les échafaudages le sous-chef
attendait la place depuis dix ans et moi
en dix jours crack si vous voyez sa tête
je manque d'eau et 1 en mi temps les
gens d'avoir d'autres réussir là où ils
ont échoué
oui parce que j avec lui qui encore les
autres quand je pense dans le bureau je
les vois ils se poussent du coude avec
des sourires en coin il y en a même qui
me lance des vannes rochelais m'a
demandé ce que j'avais fait mon patron
qui si vous lui avez dit je vais édition
vous le demande
après ben oui mais il m'a répondu
justement sur l'île de man faut que je
sache
votre saga des jaloux vous pourrez
jamais empêcher ça vous avez tenu tête
aux patrons et ça lui a plu il aime les
hommes
les hommes qui ont une forte
personnalité c'est un original
alors je vais dire matin une jeune dame
horde si le patron n'a pas une idée
originale derrière la tête
à quoi vous pensez y siègent je compte
sur vous pour m'aider à y voir clair
un patron qui donne plus d'argent qu'ils
ne doit prépare un mauvais coup c'est
sûr c'est toute la morale que vous tirez
de votre brillante avancement de la
morale capitaliste on a cherché un
médicament à prendre toutes les deux
faut vous dire qu'il m'a envoyé à
l'hôpital beaujon pour un tel choc
vous voulez dire à cech
ouais
et mon frère aîné radio les analyses
j'ai craché je fais pipi pendant deux
jours il voulait savoir si j'étais en
bonne santé pourquoi monsieur le
directeur tient tout de même voilà
quinze ans tellement voit sur tous les
chantiers au risque de me casser la
figure et les subitement il a peur
plusieurs trappes la rougeole
il a une peur bleue des toutes les
maladies alors ikea s'assurer que ses
collaborateurs les plus proches sont en
bonne santé quoi de plus naturel qui
veut plus que gênant vélo à mon travail
pourtant c'était bon ça pour ma santé
sont de ce fait de l'exercice dans votre
nouvelle situation vous n'y pensez pas
oui le chef du service des ventes arrivé
à eloyes son travail comme un ouvrier
l'âge ouvrions touchent leur bagnole
adaptif à présent oui oui mais donne a
renvoyé son chauffeur veut prendre tous
les matins à la maison il me ramène soir
c'est bien simple quand ma femme m'a vu
le chauffeur ouvert la porte il réitéré
sa casquette elle est tombée dans les
pommes et les sens mais quand je vous ai
dit que j'allais gagner trois fois plus
il a remis ça l actrice j'avais fait un
mauvais coup qu'elle et soupçonneuse la
qua non j'ai pas encore osé lui dire que
j'avais gagné un appartement à la tombe
c'est vrai monsieur assi les oubliés
vous féliciter merci mais qu'est ce que
c'était que cette loterie personne n'a
l'air de le savoir dans la maison
quand j'ai demandé aux huissiers s'il
avait gagné quelque chose ils m'ont dit
qu'elles notre visite est au courant
vous n'avez rien gagné
non parce que moi je ne gagne jamais
rien aux jeux de hasard
oh là là bas faut pas désespérer aller
moi non plus avant jamais jamais pu
toucher le cuir c'est même dans le
désordre en avant comme ça nous avons
tous au départ dans notre vie un petit
capital de chance à dépenser et vous
n'avez pas encore entamé le vôtre mon
petit capital à votre avis oui je veux
dire vous avez subi des influences
astrales bénéfice à 1
vous y croyez vous aux ben oui mais
surtout monsieur le directeur est en jeu
c'est bien ma femme m'avait offert une
travaille pour ma fête
il me l'a fait enlever il m'a donnée
celle ci à la place d'un poids en bas
les jolies jolies seulement je suis pas
rentré chez moi avec vous êtes penser
que c'est une autre femme double offert
même n'avait qu'à lui dire la vérité
vous voyez dire un doute que le patron
d'african ou d'une carte
a voir je prêtais ce qu'il l'aimé pour
la biennale me diraient non mais
j'aurais tout de même bien voulu
comprendre ya bien une explication mais
j'ose pas y croire
quelle explication que mon beau garçon
il pas facile à expliquer j'ai pensé
qu'il s'était imaginé que tous les grecs
et si vous vouliez dire monsieur que
tous les grecs eux je vais tout de même
maintenir sur mes gardes
mes joueurs avant le coeur net parce que
si c'est ça je serais remonté sur les
poutrelles à vous le dire à monsieur
vignon cas le voilà bonjour monsieur je
ne signerai sylvie ciel et député maire
de plaisir grignon a téléphoné il a
demandé que vous le rappelle cas
d'urgence il n'avait pas l'air content
c'est mademoiselle marie claude a appelé
lundi qu'elle a bien reçu votre message
qui viendra troisième fait pas prendre
pour ce soir deux places pour l'opéra
pour l'opéra je lui ai alors ainsi
comment tu as lu
alors on prend bien ces médicaments web
accord il faut que nous soyons en santé
sera en bonne santé qu'est-ce que vous
avez là rien je me suis brûlé on en est
moins une cigarette
non c'est à cette extraordinaire c'est
étonnant c'est stupéfiant c'est jacques
loubet tu commences ne vous est-il
arrivé
d'ailleurs ces manuels virale carbonneau
qui m'a fait un pansement mais ça valait
pas la peine je vous demande pardon
j'aurais dû faire attention y'a pas de
mal patron c'est pas votre faute pour ça
il ya pas de normes de sécurité
regardez moi aussi je me suis brûlé on
allume à montcy casse alors encore une
coïncidence
bah vous l'avez dit vous avez vu ma
petite poupée m'appelle s'inquiète
poupée alors on n'est pas trop bousculés
on s ennuie pas
ah je ne veux pas dans son nez si on
s'ennuyait je trouverais moyen de vous
distraire
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les patchs et
mon tailleur j'aime bien pourquoi pas il
est moins cher
je vous avais donné 300 mille francs
ouais bah la différence comment vous
avez bien fait ramener un point
seulement il vous a complètement raté
votre costume vous êtes fagotée comme ça
poserait travail vous êtes carbonneau
m'a trouvé très chic ou encore les poses
sont trop basses
la poitrine est trop court et rapide et
plus c'est pas l'argent chaussures j'ai
bien aimé tourner et vous non
tournez-vous agir
je vous en prie achille donnez vous
vous ne toucherez pas
ses premiers pas ce que je pensais vous
avez un pile votre pantalon tombe très
fâché le directeur comme on tient si les
bretelles par les vives craintes et les
épaules projet
problème ces nouveaux talents s'est fait
voler les gens peu compliqué mais ça va
pas être simple mais très simple
d'accord jamais arrêté à la ceinture
mais vu un aussi bon oui c'est faisable
vous avez le député maire sur la
première j'avais prend lui aussi
non
mes respects ne sait pas tout est
possible mais c'est une épouvantable
erreurs que nous allons réparer mégapole
mire excuses à monsieur le député maire
mille excuses pas mal non
on avait bien ces cinq tonnes de gravats
de rennes l1 n'en fait pas un drame
j'ai voyagé cru bien faire c'est rouge
flec et m'a dit de votre part de faire
des charges et les gravats à l'adresse
en question j'aurais dû me méfier assez
vous allez robin temps mais non mais non
carbonneau fait le nécessaire pour faire
enlever ces cinq tonnes de gravats et
dita rousselet que j'ai deux mots à midi
tout de suite à la voilà voilà c'est
arrivé c'est ce député maire qui avait
atteint vous avez bien fait bravo à si
bon bon là je vous le prenez comme ça je
peux lui faire décharger une autre
livraison à lyon ça suffit comme ça
parce que je peux avoir besoin puis
l'alba n'ont pas la moindre
autre mauvaise j'ai compris la raison du
plus fort n'est pas toujours la
meilleure
pardon oui s'il vous plaît à dix
livraisons du plus fort n'est pas
toujours la meilleure livraison du plus
fort il passe à aa
vous en avez d'autres comme ça
j'en fais tout le temps ah bon c'est en
déchargeant qu'on devient forgeron
ah ah ah qu'est ce que ça veut dire à
yannick noah marion riom a tranché
prévenu en vaut la peine
[Applaudissements]
voilà je te présente
achille vamos vamos c'est un belge
non c'est un ingrédient présente itunes
après mois marque le jeu s'appellerait
achi si je peux amener ici mais si mais
si
alors mon tonton tu as besoin de moi et
déjeuners d'affaires j'ai quelque chose
à te demander total tout ce que tu
voudras montante antilles c'est bien que
j'aie rihanna tu refuses et algériennes
à lui refusé mairie comprend qu'il veut
bien susan on s'attend à ce que tous les
grands champions oui mais ça n'intéresse
pas notre ami non pas si ma branche
matériel pouvait pas savoir être
sollicité de tous je suis très content
de cette bonne nouvelle vient je retiens
et 10 mois qui sait c'est mon
collaborateur désormais le plus intime
mon alter ego veulent et il atteint 10
dans des germes article bien belle mère
dfi a bien sûr monsieur n'y a plus de
place à l'opéra pour ce soir devant les
deux doigts pour les folies bergères
c'est la même chose on devenir les
folies bergères tu m'amènes aux folies
bergère j'ai fait de la danse quand
j'étais petite je voulais être dans ses
rangs mais si ça a toujours été mon rêve
vous savez au la laddh descend de grand
escalier tu devais te plume ans de règne
les vols je vous dis que je montre
comment s'annonce cette région il a dit
c'est dit c'est dit
cet argument
oui
il est tout rouge vous n'aimez pas j'ai
pas la météo fait du berger n'avait
jamais été aux folies bergères vol à une
erreur qu'il faudra réparer le plus vite
possible a dit moi achille soyez assez
aimable pour aller jeter un coup d'oeil
sur le chantier bourgogne j'ai
l'impression que notre architecte
montclos nous a raconté des salades sur
l'isolation thermique opa projet
courageux tout arranger du doubs pas
jeter un coup d'oeil ça suffirait à
venir jacques diouf c'est tout vous
voulez pas que j'aimerais tout de même
bien être à peu près au sérieux
aurait pu oser aller on doit mieux qu'il
arrive là-bas donc son pantalon
j'ai comme l'impression que tous veulent
être débarrassé du toi tu es une fine
observatrice je voulais rester seul avec
voilà je ne pourrais pas t'accompagner
ce soir aux folies bergères pourquoi je
vais t'expliquer à son nom alors moi qui
me réjouit c'est que tous les juifs
rien n'est changé c'est achi qui
t'accompagnera la grecque
pourquoi tu as quelque chose contre les
grecs la non bien sûr que non mais j'ai
rien non plus pour celui là il y avait
l'homme bat pour un grec elle est plutôt
tarte
moi même je ne suis pas un apple au toit
moto toi mais toi tu es ma beauté aux
messieurs mapuku data
c'est bien possible j'ai un service à te
demande alors c'était ça fait combiné
davance ne plus rien de caché ou mejia
tu sais ça carbure là-dedans su principe
est que j'en ai l'air là on va passer à
mon chéri trois passes
tu n'auras pas à leur gré a alors ça si
tu me prend par les sentiments
voilà je voudrais que tu lui porte
chance aux grecs
pourquoi ça me regarde tu es une
mascotte lui une mabrouk tu portes
changée kia or je voulais faire un
transfert de chance provisoirement sur
le grec
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
après le spectacle tu l'emmènes chez toi
en drap vert et ensuite tim hely le mail
où tu veux te mêle pas que lui et moi
aussi je veux la non non non non non ça
je toucherai la main bras quand tu
voudras mais pour le team et lila mais
lula tu vois ça tu as me suis fait un
peu tout de même
tu sais très bien que le seul
attouchements de ma main gauche suffit
pour porter chance
je sais aussi que le contact le plus
intime et meilleurs pour la propagation
des ondes bénéfique pour mais je t'aime
moi mon tour je t'aime sais pas si je
pourrais tu sais tu penseras moi c'est
ed rabin nom du lot ce sera dur et ma
pudeur qu'est ce que t'en fais tapis
d'occuper le jeu
j'en estima s'ajusterait d'ailleurs
dumas boire vite si je peux me bluffe
lui si je monte a pris quelques centimes
g de ciment par an tantôt on dirait
plutôt c'est toi qui était ce une
enveloppe que j'étais préparée pour
calmer sa pudeur et faire taire des
scrupules bien mon tour tourne basse je
ferai pour le mieux puisque c'est ce que
tu veux m'aimer didon s'il résiste jolie
violent je te fais confiance fait comme
pour toi mais n'oublie pas qu'il y ait
ces gens lancent un grand sens de
l'honneur et du devoir en présence d'une
jolie femme
tout homme normalement constitué c'est
ce que lui commandent l'honneur et le
devoir
mehdi dont celle de faire rien de penser
qu'un autre vas prendre ta place
ça me ferait plutôt plessis non mais tu
m'as kg est toi tu dis un peu compliqué
un didot devrait pas venir avec nous par
hasard longtemps mauvaise études et puis
on amènerait maquiller le si c'est pas
libre ce soir savez le courrier a signé
ses jambons et ben je me sens jeune
faire bella va prendre du temps pour lui
tu sais je mets ta robe que tu préfères
laquelle nous voyons le petit four
traqueraient moulant la meilleure avec
le grand bain vert pomme en table
discret mais c'est ça oui n'oublie pas
que les chauffeurs passent de prendre
avis qualité un bien montants investis
en commerces y monte autant tu fais pas
ça marc lajoie qui me fait ça c'est
paris ça fait parler poupoupidou
elle simplicité elle est charmante et je
comprends qu'on lève vous trouverez vos
places au contrôle pour ce soir monsieur
de bon fauteuil le 41 et 43 au premier
rang je n'aime pas beaucoup vous
sous-entendu carbonneau il n'y a pas de
sous-entendus monsieur m'a plu tout ce
que vous avez découvert sur un monologue
pas grand chose monsieur se son père est
né au pid et sa mère à connerré ah oui
le pays du sirtaki un pays de la
rillette connerré dans la salle marié
depuis 25 ans un homme sale une vie sans
histoire
en lieu et monotone il n'a pas de
passe-temps dos au but si j'y venais
monsieur il a une passion c'est pas du
tout ce que vous croyez
tous les dimanches qui part à la
campagne faire de longues marches à pied
cueillir des cryptogames mais les femmes
et frappe
c'est un homme rangé sérieux dont ils
s'ennuient et vous qu il dit nous allons
essayer de lui rendre la vie plus gai
n'allait tout de même pas le jeter dans
les bras de cèpes suffi pour que non il
est vrai qu'elle en a l'habitude
rien que la semaine dernière il est
envoyé en l'air avec ses trois
directeurs qui ont signé le contrat des
hlm de plus tôt
bah c'est pas que je peux envoyer à sa
place et honteux me suis retiré ce que
vous venez bill janaudy dans l avant
c'est vous dire et je préfère m'en aller
vous finirez de signer le courrier tout
seul si je ne vois pas je vous souhaite
une bonne soirée avec votre mascotte
n'oubliez pas vos jumelles sur tout
les envoyer
paradis son venin d'ascot mes amis
heureux celui que le skate d'intel damas
quand un signal et coûterait patron
alors pas d'inquiétude à vous faire tout
est en ordre à manger intérêts jeter un
coup d'oeil le plus vite possible
asseyez-vous achille j'ai besoin de vous
si je peux vous êtes retire sa vie je
devais conduire ce soir marie foule aux
folies bergère je viens de recevoir un
coup de téléphone de clients extrêmement
important qui désirent précisément me
voir ce soir pour des affaires du plus
haut intérêt donc comprenez oui vous
voyez où je connais très bien peut voler
m'envoyer à votre place
recevoir ce client de passage à lyon
c'est tout pas non je préfère que vous
accompagnez marie-claude aux folies
bergères avant ah bon pourquoi on n'est
pas libre ben si c'est seulement là j'ai
dit que vous n'aviez jamais été aux
folies bergères je ne pensais pas vous
en fournir l'occasion aussitôt ouverte
yves accroissement j'ai ma femme vous
êtes en service commandé achille
ah bah oui bien sûr comme ça je voulais
pas besoin de lui dire où vous allez ni
aller qu'ils lèveraient pas besoin
j'assume le savez pas c'est que les plus
grands il faut vous dire que je ne lui
ai jamais donner de prétexte
une femme jalouse n'a pas besoin de
prétextes même amusé il marie claude est
au courant
elle est ravie de famille comblée elle
vous manger des yeux d'avoir un fils
nathan ciel vous déplaît vous me le
dites je n'insiste pas j'ai pas dit ça
au contraire et vous trouve très
séduisant elle nous prouve grand beau
enveloppé bien grand assis pour des gens
plus petit que vous allez passer une
bonne soirée mondaine achille merci
docteur
tu le directeur et amusez vous bien si
vous m'envoyez le chauffeur a bitter
faites moi confiance on a un dicton
grève leur jamais d'accueil dans nos
jardins dont ton voisin on distinguerait
fournissent à regrette évidemment rien
que pour l'occasion qu'il fallait en
aucun cas y est très zen et non moi je
me permets de lui faire la cour
les femmes françaises à tort qu'on leur
fasse takoucht et qu'on les fasse rire
ah j'adore faire des blagues
oui j'ai remarqué c'est avec le député
maire invita soyez tranquille vous ne
risquez rien même si elle me provoquer
supposition bien sûre je me mettrai en
travers il faudrait même passé sur le
court c'est exactement ce que j'espère
oui
[Applaudissements]
et
grasset bonjour madeleine j'y passais
par votre bureau on est encore au
créneau comme vous savez bien tous les
trois mois c'est réglé monsieur vignon
de teum en bleu ciel soit impeccable au
bleu ciel
alors ça on peut pas dire que vous voyez
la vie la même couleur aux comptes est
devenu pour me jeter des vous croyez pas
si bien dire c'est pot de fleurs et pour
vous doit être ça je ne m'attendais pas
à autre chose comme remerciement de
votre part mais ça ne fait rien
j'ai pas grand qu'une droite
pourquoi vous auriez de la rancune
contre aulnoye d'ailleurs mes filles à
cause de votre mine de cul passé quand
vous me parlez et des oyats
d'incendiaires que vont jeter en bas
alors c'est soit qu'il ait pas surtout
si vous madoré vous le cacher bien mais
ça ne fait rien su belle fille sur un
coeur d'or un coeur d'or d'or tish au
raid
en réalité vous êtes jalouses parce que
je suis là mabrouka d'alexandre et ben
vous savez moi ça fait 20 ans que je
mabrouk is de montgon fait oui mais pas
tout à fait les façons si vous voyez le
dessin aux multiples bouquin qui m'a
apporté des fleurs
c'est pourquoi je pourrais être jeune
mais aussi je rétorque que c'est pour
m'amuser quand vous voulez son joli
[Rires]
alors là c'est la première fois j'avais
rigoler diamant la dernière fois c'était
en 1960 quand ma femme m'a quitté je me
demande même si elle n'y a pas été pour
quelque chose s'est fait que je te dise
mais à mon avis elle est amoureuse de
toi on n'en fait jamais remarqué avec
son air de chaisière elle te dévore
littéralement dur car mon nom ben dis
donc qu'est ce qui l'a t'on agile et
très bien dit didon comment était-elle
ya vingt ans comme aujourd'hui à mon
dieu quel ordre
bon attention maintenant c'est l'heure
de ta surprise et leur vie me guette
talleyrand que quatre raids allaient
reculer de champigné 200 filiales et
d'amour technip métallique gris hier
tant les voies avec un chez l'homme et
un plein panier il absolument voulu
partager avec toi mais qu'est ce qu'il
en fait les mange bien sûr il y mange
mais les fous pourquoi il s'y coller aux
champignons
je crois ou bien ton caisse qui m'a dit
déjà ah bah oui qu'il y avait ce
qu'était bon à manger et ce qui n'était
pas ce jeu c'est ma personne un passage
c'est pas moi on croyait de faire
plaisir
il ya des espèces qui sont vénéneuse et
même mortelles il va sans point donné
pourquoi ils sont pas bons sur ses rives
alors si tu en sais rien pourquoi
fais-tu tout circuit dans la manger je
ne sais pas tu veux pas qu'en plus j'ai
surveillé ses repas qu'est ce que tu as
dit il on la mange et je ne sais pas ce
que dira même intervenant au nom pas
pourquoi veux-tu que je t'appelle
carbonneau parce que tu t'appelles
alexandre mais on a plus ma secrétaire
en effet s'il est à ça et là à manger je
suis passionné ça y est allé me chercher
me donne pas un titre de la nba pour
coiffer le seul contre prison que je
connaisse oiseaux j'ai ce qu'est ce que
vous avez mangé mais l'arrière manche et
du bassiste à 10h30 devant mon boulot ce
n'est pas venu ce matin monsieur les
maladresses et passionné de sport à
l'heure actuelle peut téléphoner suffit
comment il n'est pas dû vous vous en
êtes pas soucié pas préoccupé lavier
paradis qu'est ce que vous ressentez de
le retirer sans toi là-bas d'or alors
alors monsieur va mon boulot je vous
passe monsieur vignon merci à l'eau
allouache épouse est vivant mais oui un
peu comment avez vous bien c'est sûr que
si vous lui avez donné des champignons
mais sont pas venimeux vous avez dit la
fed funds est en fait vous avez fait là
votre matelas plutôt mon coeur
non pardon achille comment vous avez
mangé vos champignons et vous allez bien
c'est sûr mais c'est très dangereux à
promettez-moi d'autres jamais recommence
et je vous attends immédiatement au
bureau comme ça je pourrais constater de
visu que vous êtes en bonne santé a tout
de suite montré s'il accroche très
lounge à la moustache qui doivent amener
bahreïni vous serrez câble vous vous
sentez mieux monsieur vous sent très
bien pourquoi mais baudelaire j'avais
des douleurs mais qu'est ce que vous
faites là je vous ai passé ma fille n'a
pas sonné sa fille chante et on voulait
quand c'est à vous ce centre
comment s'est passée cette journée la
campagne très bien j'étais sûr que ça
lui réussit ils m'adorent des terrains
radio alors tout va bien mais un peu
trop peut-être
c'est à dire qu'il est amoureux fou de
moi et ça me pèse d'avoir un métier qui
ne pense que tu me lis la mel tient
même à la campagne ça n'a pas arrêté
il valait plus on attend la suite
c'est qu'ils parlent de quitter sa femme
à blessy de vendre l'appartement qu'il a
gagné à la tombola et de rentrer en
grâce avec moi je viens de dire
il a une petite maison de pêcheur sur le
port il veux m'y installer il dit que
l'air de la mer c'est lubrifiants soit
enfin voyons non alors tu me vois moi au
pirée voit dans des sardines en dansant
sur terre cuite
je suis d'humeur et pour cela rien de
spécialement temps en tout cas pas plus
que d'habitude un non simplement une dit
qu'il a découvert l'amour on lui en
demande pas tant
c'est invraisemblable invraisemblable je
te remercie alors tu me crois un capable
d'éveiller des passionnés pas des
pensions qui engendre des catastrophes
doit évidemment que jamais amoureux
noirmont veux tu dire cela continue nous
allons te fatigue pas je peux très bien
vivre sans sa mère mais je sais bien que
si j'avais pas fais ta main pour gamin
tu aurais jamais fait de moi ta
maîtresse humains mabrouka parce que tu
es ma maîtresse tu es ma maîtresse parce
que enfin c'est était écrit oui en tout
cas ce qui est pas écrit c'est ont
protégé soit à la fusion
mais je suis lessivé mois à tordre à ce
point le ça n'arrête pas je te dis ça
l'obsédé où tu vas
j'étais un peu fatigué depuis une
semaine voilà brusquement que je suis et
puis non toi de toute façon rien d'en
parler cette fatigue alors en train de
trouver quelque chose qui fige le calme
et un match où tu rates ivoire de femme
a toujours des arguments des arguties dh
une léger tout essayé je te dit tout
quand je refuse tu sais pas ce qu'il
fait il dit que je n'aime plus qui va se
flingue à la poste alors faudrait savoir
ce que tu veux tu m'as demandé une forte
chance oui ou non moi jusqu'à présent
j'ai évité que te poser des questions
indiscrètes à mais là franchement
j'estime que j'ai droit à quelques
explications aucune comme tu voudrais
demander de rendre heures mais c'est
toujours pas ça c'est entendu mais
pourquoi parce que c'est un peu mon
frère et que je veux sont bonnes
plaignent alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce que je fais plus rien jusqu'à
nouvel an va tout de même à vous je suis
pas une fille texte que tu as une crise
d'urticaire chez nous mais ces
malentendus de l'urticaire géant mais je
n'y pense pas autrefois bruyant mais ils
risqueraient l'être encore plus énervé
alors là petit jésus où allons-nous
encore bono ou paris lâche ils veulent
nous tuer des péris claude de faire des
bêtises qu'ils peuvent engendrer de
graves et déjà fait monsieur ici la
situation dans le domaine calamiteuse
déjà bien en avance mais puis chez vous
je voulais d'ailleurs déjà vous en
parlait en huit jours votre protégé a
bénéficié de deux avancement de chef du
service des ventes à la direction des
équipements collectifs alors à la
dernière réunion les délégués du comité
d'entreprise ont demandé des
explications salue d'ailleurs de pas
assez pas le rap je suis le seul
susceptibles d'apprécier les qualités
professionnelles de muscu m'a beaucoup
donné dans leur raconter ça ça peut les
amuser un moment qui font des gorges
chaudes et bévues et des gardes de votre
frère astral connaissez pas la dernière
d'un mage l'aurait bien j'ai trouvé
nous allons créer allons inventer un
poste
ainsi plus de jalousie de hiérarchie de
subordination quel poste directeur pour
la qualité de la vie dans l'habitat ça
veut rien dire
ça sert à rien mais ça fait bien joli
mais d'être révisées parce que marshall
qu'organisera
la commis d allô oui qui dit vous faites
monter directement dans le bureau du
patron monsieur marshall d'izza
messieurs les directeurs de revenir dans
son bureau d'urgence après après chère
madame bonjour madame bonjour madame 9a
demoiselle au excusez moi il n'y a pas
d'offre ans je voulais voir monsieur
vignon oui j'essaie permettez moi de me
présenter je suis madame carbonneau
la secrétaire de monsieur vignes ont
enchanté c'est vous merci monsieur
vigneault ne tardera pas je les fais
cherchez vous prendrez bien quelque
chose en mon nom je dois vous déranger
même motif et d'opinion me reprocherait
de ne pas vous d'avoir bien traités nous
allons prendre un petit whisky au nom
alors pas d'alcool
[Applaudissements]
c'est faux un nom ça coule bien moi je
trouvais tout cas si vous cherchez une
petite cigarette
ce papa avril à sept longueurs du
fauteuil
moi j'allais chercher mes origines
vous pouvez reprendre si vous aimez
pourtant c'est par là c'est la fête tant
pis ralenti par la tête
peut-être qu'est ce que tu fais là bas
je pourrais te demander la même chose
enfin je te laisse à la maison tu
m'avais vue ne viendrait pas au bureau
aujourd'hui
ben c'est vrai mais je suis à coups de
fils du patron je suis parti derrière
toi à est bien assez vite
toi aussi en somme qui profitait de mon
projet pour venir faire une petite
visite à mon à notre bienfaiteur
oui non oui non non c'est vrai je n'ai
pas dit que je viendrais tu avais oublié
je n'avais pas jugé utile à maintien et
été mis sur son 31 et c'est normal non
et tu te prennes asta comme une femme du
monde ça aussi c'est normal
d'ailleurs chez toi ici au firmware ou
enfin chez nous on n'est pas chez nous
voyons a pourtant j'aurais juré que tu
était la maîtresse la maîtresse de la
maison
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes tu ne
drague pas non hélas cette bouteille
tranquille tétras est pour ton petit
mari h il ne boit pas que si tu supporte
pas l'alcool c'est gentil tu
t'intéresses est ma santé oui d'ailleurs
il va falloir qu'on reparle de ce que tu
as fait hier parce qu'aujourd'hui je ne
trouve pas bonne mine
oui mais quand mais quand même avec vos
savoirs je vais avoir bonne mine
mais ça va a haché sa part mais qu'est
ce que tu m'as tu a filtré à leur ego
l'eau mais j'suis rigolo un petit trou
contre onet chef du service des ventes
et depuis 5 minutes directeur à
l'habitat à la vie d'habitat à la
qualité de la vie dans l'habitat
je grave j'ai voltige havrais mis en
tire enfin si je ne vois pas où tu veux
en venir
je suis ton supino t'énerve pas chérie
je suis calme comme la mère à temps
forts comme la mère grand avec calme je
ne te manger ce qu'il fallait les bonnes
grâces de sa majesté l'avancement par la
femme assise pas de scandale
mais qu'est ce que tu vas chercher leur
fille je m'attendais à ça tu vas tu
n'aimes pas il me dit on doit bien
rigoler dans la maison tient la qualité
de la victime ans rochelais va sûrement
me demander si j'apprécie les qualités
de la femme qu'on va chier c'est pas
possible tu auras du chat j'accepte hs1
attend qu'il arrive nous casser la
gueule à ton amant il reprendre la
musette en vitesse
j'avais plus besoin de points pour
m'occuper de la promotion h et tu sais
plus ce que tu fais et ce que ce qui me
ferait bien entendu mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette folle qui vient de
bousculer la croche tard il voulait
qu'on ne sait pas mais vous voyez j'ai
jamais faites pas les innocents genou
cassé la gueule main merci vous êtes
vivre détourné par la première censure
ça m'empêche pas d'y voir clair voir
quoi chercher la femme la femme merci
vous êtes ma réputation ainsi de marche
plus dans des combines
20 bon boulot serait france à lui y est
il remonte sur ces chantiers plus dans
les bonnes questions
[Applaudissements]
capoter un projet mal
ok c'était une femme de ma vie mais oui
je sais elle me l'a dit vous l'a dit que
les gentils tout de même mais ça
n'empêche pas couché avec vous pourquoi
elle a fait ça pour vous porté chance
puisque vous voulez le savoir vous
foutez de la gueule alors la chine
vous n'êtes pas dans votre état normes
parce que mon état normal c'est d'être
cocu je laime pouvez pas comprendre et
si je sais voulait l'emmener au pirée au
pirée non c'est un autre que j'ai dit ça
oui c'est le plus que vous dites vous
êtes saoul comme un polonais je suis
grecque
attention laissez moi moi qui se finit
ce gros chagrin un grand garçon qu'on
veut nous sommes de bons petits
camarades en petits camarades prend pas
la pousuite son copain mais sauf si ce
copal lui prête pour faire le jeu vient
prêter c'est moi qui voulait prêter mais
je pensais pas que vous tomberiez
amoureux fou de ma région c'est pour ça
c'est pour ça que vous n'avez présenter
pour avoir le champ libre
sans lui on voit qu'il est retenu de
votre ampli avec marie-claude comment
vous faites l'amour comme un dément
et c'est le cas
fbi avant la fin de l'unité pêche et se
passer six mois celle là aussi c'est moi
qui devrait joindre le vrai qu'on a et
moi alors vous vous n'êtes pas mariée à
marie-claude tandis que l'odeur si sa
dette la folle qu'elle fut grand ce qui
nous a bousculés quand vous êtes entré 1
a toujours pas dit qu était la femme
qu'il aime c'est la mienne
il va battre il va dire qui la connaît
pas votre femme vous l'avez voulu garder
là mais j'en fasse enfin ça c'est la
meilleure lorsqu'elle vous entendez en
fait escale au début des pluies acides
qui ont l'amour du ciel
vous avez raison mais moi ça j'en ai
marre j'aime laisser tomber dans le vide
s'il habite près s'il vous avez vous
plus à lui toujours et bien sûr la
chanter ça fait deux mois je vais vous
expliquer pour emmener à sin revenus at
il dit
ensuite vous êtes mon frère est ce qui
va pas chercher jeudi que vous êtes mon
frère ouais je suis fils unique 1 c'est
qu'en plus il s'allierait la mémoire de
master d'abord vous n'avez pas une tête
de grève vous avez plutôt une tête de
ecoutez-moi aux autres après celle
encore n'y a plus on attend savez je
suis un passionné de jeux de stratégie
près les hommes défaire des astres des
frais rasteau des jumeaux du ciel sommes
nés le même jour à la même heure tout ce
qui vous arrive marie que vous dites de
ça et odette sa note francine ces prêts
frère que je suis longtemps recherché
les empreintes trouvées il ya 15 ans
touchant et c'est la vérité odette eudes
le connais poule
c'est vrai quoi ils vous parlez de marie
claude marie claude
j'aurais jamais dû là c'est une mascotte
je voulais prêtait pour qu'elle vous
porte chance tram fallait le dire tout
de suite monsieur vigneault rappelez-moi
l'ex alex en moi aussi je commencerai
croire aux petits astres dans le ciel
hors du vent pour fêter ce beau joueur
en la plus petite équipe plus j'ai été
tutoyé aussi je peux et je peux tu peux
tu fais tout petit peu surpris
l homme d associer géante pas ce que
j'ai fait avec marie-claude et non mais
il faut être raisonnable plus de folie
elle use ou jamais de l'homme aime bien
le servir avait bu six mois jamais à
faire à cheval non frères astral je ne
savais pas qu'elle était avec nous je
lis blond je ne traîne pas avec des
citronniers le patron maintenant
madrelle pas plus moi et je l'envoie
incident menace au cinéma ça tombe bien
pour la bonne nouvelle que je viens vous
annoncer les délégués du comité
d'entreprise ont décrété la grève
générale à cause de lui au général
[Applaudissements]
et c'est pas tout nous avons frisé la
grève à cause de mon boulot et à cause
de ces avancements successifs et trop
rapides heureusement tout est rentré
dans l'ordre maintenant s'en est passé
des choses pendant mon absence très bon
alors maintenant plus de temps à perdre
faut profiter de la situation pour
présenter lundi n'a pas pas à temps un
pea
quel un patient attendre mais pourquoi
tu me dis tout baigne dans l'huile et
ben justement pour prendre garde à
passer mouillante et a mené l'assaut
habilement qu'est ce que tu vas chercher
tous étaient conviés les travaux du
professeur albrecht madeleine mail m tu
me cache quelque chose
oh non non je t'ai tout raconter ou bien
alors je comprends pas les réticences
il ne le dit pas que tu te gonfle au
dernier moment comme anne chaon vue mais
dégonfler c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est un
gentil petit soldat
alors que tu te fais pas de bile temps
plus que c'est moi qui vais monter en
première ligne mais tu n'es pas à
quelques jours près oui parce que plus
tôt il en a donné son accord plutôt
frais pena tu connais pas pas mais dès
qu'il se répand sera qu'à une chose de
voir marié mais ces deux s'aperçoit que
nous l'avons relais tu passes tu te
rends compte et puis c'est ton intérêt
comme le mien tu t'es mouillé dans cette
histoire moi depuis 20 ans est
imperméable
alors tu me dis cache il est papa file
le parfait amour
n'empêche fallait en faire autant tu me
disais qu'ils ne se quittent plus et de
la passion est anormal à toi je ne vois
pas ça va pas non le respect de la
hiérarchie
ça m'a échappé à personne que ce soit
plus naïve je suis attendu suivent infos
jeunes si ce monsieur est déjà tu as
l'air préoccupé mais non
comment va-t-on faire astral en pleine
forme tu vas le corps dans un instant
dis donc pourquoi dis-tu s'il est arrivé
les 10 heures parce que je me suis fait
la grasse matinée qu'au fond je peux
faire ça quand il vient ici il ne fait
de bêtise monumentale madeleine m'a dit
qu'il n'avait plus de fonctions
officielles non j'ai dû le licencier
sous la pression du comité d'entreprise
pour avoir la paix il est maintenant mon
conseiller technique à titre privé
mon bras tout le monde peut pas être man
show
bonjour descendre bonjour monsieur
frédéric monfils 11e mondial c'est mon
nord tuant presque live tu passais la
croûte ça doit venir du saucisson ou pas
manger c'est trois grands de venir ici
je n'ai pas couché chez moi pourquoi la
salle n'affiche que l'apporteur respect
tous ces cons qu'ils sont les miens sont
pas les tiens je suis ton bras droit
faut bien qu'ils savent dire que dans un
véritable guet du coucher par terre mon
appartement que j'ai quand même dire et
tombola mais comme il était un mythe je
suis venu ici avec mon petit quand ce
que les secours au fauteuil quand il ya
du mois qu'il a sorti sans vous dire que
le battage une habitude de prendre 2
euros plat avec a fait partie de ce oui
ça s'explique avec une vie active à
tokyo de vie sédentaire il faut manger
moins j'ai faim il ne tient qu'à quoi
que je fasse de l'exercice c'est toi qui
m'a enfermée dans ses bureaux tu sais
bien que ça nous fait du mal je n'aime
pas me priver de manger sous prétexte
que tu as une constitution fragile
déjà que témoin empêche de voir
marie-claude c'est mauvais pour notre
coeur pour le reste on ajouté
j'ai lu dans le dernier numéro de corde
à pacifier toi
je suis au large mais je disais j'ai vu
l'article d'un médecin très sérieux qui
dit comme ça ne fatigue pas tant on en a
envie
en fait on ne se force pas et c'est
pareil pour la nourriture mais pour le
boulot c'est peut-être autre chose
pourquoi tu ne penses pas que tu fasses
un peu les deux hommes regardent par la
fenêtre des boues et parmi celles que
j'ai commandé j'ai fait une affaire et
je t'ai demandé d'en commander il sent
qu'il a demandé combien 5000 tu te crois
pas c'est un peu exagéré non j'ai eu
après il est bien pris je vais t'en
décerné moins de prix le roi dès que je
fous de 5000 bout adoubé m on serait m'a
dit qu'il allait trouver la place et
vous serez qui va se chercher une deux
places
t'as pas l'air content si je suis ravi
tu planète est alors de ne pas faire
d'exercice et bien tu vas en faire de
l'exercice
li 4900 brouette qui restent les
derniers une par une à pied cinq jours à
aubervilliers sanaa 30 de temps il fera
tellement crevé deux soirs prend pas le
temps de faire le tour des bars et des
bistrots ça bien forcé de rentrer chez
toi que tu vas tu ne peux pas me
reprocher leurs proches la victime m
depuis que tu es révélé que tu as mon
frère tu sais que tu m'as gâche pas
maman ah oui la sortie de me ronger me
torture si moi je le hais je le jette de
même bien droit de profiter un peu de
l'existence non tu sais pas ce que c'est
toi tu as tout du héros assassiné qui
avait placé je crois que ça m'est tombé
tout petit dans le bec
je me suis battu moi j'en ai bavé et pas
seulement dans les bars y supprimer mon
bonheur non j'ai droit à d'autres un
peureux bon dieu que tu me fait de
l'oeil à l'école
alors quoi rattrape toi profites-en
présente ou plus justement de pardon de
m'être laissé emporter tu as raison
à moi les petites femmes et la grande
bouffe avant leur fais moi confiance on
n'a pas fini de rigoler tu verras ton
fois tankers pour l'estomac tout le
reste ne pensera même plus
tu vas prix de l'achat j'y penserai plus
pendant un an
pourquoi alors oui je te les cacher les
médecins sont formels
je n'ai plus qu'une année à vivre tu es
sûr que ça ce n'est pas certain qu'ils
ont découvert que j'avais la même tous
que la dame aux camélias qui ceint la
dame aux camélias tu connais pas alors
prenez pas tout le monde l on y mange
mon pauvre vieux elle entend oui ou non
ces programmes
comment c'est pas grave elle en est mort
violente et plus qui m'arrive depuis et
ça va bien je suivrai ton conseiller
j'oublierai celui du médecin et je ne
prolongerai pas en faisant attention la
pauvre petite années qui me restent à
vie je vais faire la foire ce sera
formidable
doucement doucement et les astres nos
destins sont liés j'ai pas envie de
passer l'armé à gauche et moi tu t'en
fous ni de toualy de moi que tu ne
penses qu'à ton intérêt est en charge
matérielle demandé tu voulais supprimer
une pauvre petite a eu deux bonnes
heures at-on fruits pour notre santé
d'ailleurs maintenant je ne lance plus
je t'en empêche pas de faire des bêtises
à moins que je ne trouve le moyen de me
libérer toi c'est impossible c'est écrit
dans les astres je sais allait rentrer
chez toi fais la terre est affamé achète
une conduite exécution d'accord
alexandre mais toi de ton côté tu vas me
faire le plaisir de te ménager je verrai
a battu voit combien on va repartir de
même qu'un média annonce que j avais tu
me feras ketchup
j'ai tout entendu vous êtes merveilleux
monsieur x qui file droit celui là en
avant dans cette histoire d'un an à
vivre
vous l'avez mater pour combien de temps
célestine arrive bref un ingénieur me
laisse tomber c'est une affaire de 2
milliards qui me passionnait saviez
pourtant bon espoir l'autre soulage
pensais que tout était gagné notre
mascotte aurait-elle perdu son potentiel
de chance je me pose la question
et j'arrive pas à me répondre peut-être
faudrait-il refaire son thème astral
effet monsieur vous avez refait son
thème astral mais regardez la carte du
ciel depuis un mois venus à quitter son
signe ici sa kung a pris le commandement
en s'efforçant de l'enseigné d'une sous
couverture et vous savez que saturne
mercure c'est la méchanceté la plus
agissants celles qui ne cesse jamais que
l'on re tassé maison double elle
contrarie nettement les voûtes de
regarder là et là si vous voulez des
détails je peux vous en donner
c'est très inquiet cet affreux c'est pas
tout c'est par rapport à votre thème
personnel que ça dit garder la la la la
ainsi demain d'ascot est venue une
sorcière et comment avez-vous eu l'idée
de refaire son thème astral
depuis quelques temps je trouvais son
pouvoir plutôt maléfique parce qu'avant
la sphère bradford junior 2 ou 3 petites
bricoles m'avait mais la puce alors
derrière j'étais là ça ne gênait pas
mais pourquoi n'en avoir jamais parlé
mais si je vous en ai parlé monsieur
mais vous m'avez répondu que sans elle
ça aurait été pire alors j'ai refait son
vous êtes merveilleux je vous remercie
infiniment vous me sauver la vie ou
mérite une récompense belle attendu
algérien sur moi préférez vous que je
vous embrasse nom laisse pas si alan
bond ne dit pas autre chose
vocifère faut s'y faire allons-y autant
de gagné
naissance hier c'était une essentielle
et parrainer son chèque de licenciement
je veux plus avoir
c'est la journée des catastrophes ont
pourtant toutes les données astral et
est fabuleusement complémentaires les
mêmes à porter qu'une bonne nouvelle
c'est une bonne nouvelle monsieur les
astres ne manque absolument voit cette
tâche il va beaucoup l'eau cet
énergumène et en plus des grecs
savez vous ce que je veux maintenant
quoi donc n'est-il pas je vous prie
messager du destin correale souvent la
tragédie antique et que la grèce envoie
au rendez-vous fatale
qu'est ce que vous allez chercher vous
faites de la tragédie alors excusez moi
la raison pour laquelle je perds la même
qu'à ruines mon équilibre et qu'il
semble qu'à chine en soit le responsable
comment récupérer tout ce bonheur perdu
hier mais je me suis penché sur le
problème asseyez vous et je crois que
j'ai trouvé la solution du tout le
potentiel de chance perdue avec marit
eau peut être récupérée au sens du bon
il ya un moyen de se concilier les
arabes le professeur albrecht un
psychiatre berlinois a mis le feu au
fond c'est j'ai lu toutes ces heures il
consacre un grand chapitre à l'hérédité
est parfaitement il n'a jamais prétendu
que les jumeaux devait filer le parfait
amour jamais seulement que leur destin
était lié indubitablement par contre il
affirme de façon péremptoire que l'union
d'enfants issus de jumeaux connaissait
une destinée exceptionnelle et apporter
aux deux familles à rayonnement l'union
des enfants issus de jumeaux civam
opulence pouvait avoir une fille qui
était fait je m'en fais occupée il en a
une
quel âge 19 ans ce merveilleux je me
battais encore mieux et elle jolie
d'ailleurs peu importe
madeleine permettez moi de vous appeler
manuel et c'est mon nom ah bah oui c'est
vrai je m'en étais jamais aperçu
madeleine pour rien au monde je voudrais
vous fatiguer ou trois mesures
mais soyez assez bonne soyez assez
aimable pour aller chercher cette nadine
20 mo pou l'os pour l'amener ici
d'urgence afin que je puisse faire son
bonheur celui de mon fils est le mien
par conséquent mais surtout ne vous
fatiguez points à tout à l'heure
madeleine toutes les deux
[Applaudissements]
alors on y va au boulot
quelle bonne surprise à payer vous non
quand allez-vous ça va je vous remercie
quelque chose qui ne va pas quelque
chose qui me passe par mon bon de faire
arrêter là pardon monsieur vignon puisse
du père et le frère de mon mari à son
frère astral oui la faune soir en tout
cas parce que si ma belle mère avait dû
à notre fils depuis 25 ans je suis marié
elle en aurait touché deux mandats de
cinq ans ce sont les noces d'argent mais
bon ces traces à plus tard mais c'est
fini on sera ravi de vous voir ça
m'étonnerait depuis qu'il a découvert
son frère pas se dire votre mari les
transformer égard shiloh filmé faut que
ça reste un secret je veux dire faut que
ça reste un secret pour les étrangers
oui alors rassurez vous ça sortira pas
c'est pourquoi on leur dit on attendait
la suite parce que c'est pas fini un
bras en lui parce que ça monte ça vous
savez yann alors j'étais allé chercher
monsieur vignes ont agité qu'il est
demandé par sa belle-soeur désastre
désastre à venir d un polar et le jumeau
illégalement ci-dessus à monsieur
achille avril est en pleine forme a
pourtant je les fais chier à la portée
hier soir avant ça mais vu depuis huit
jours il rentre sous tous les soirs hier
il a plu au score pour le paillasson
s'était essuyé les pieds dessus la
pousse un hurlement vous savez c'est
aussi la chine non oscars c'est mon père
c'est l'émeute ou où il a passé la nuit
et bien dans son panier comme d'habitude
non monsieur h il a mis alors à leur
liste avec et ce n'est pas toutefois
encore ça ne m'étonnerait pas avec
l'argent qu'il gagne maintenant qu'il
aille voir les filles au madame pas mon
boulot ce qu'est ce que vous allez
machine et qu'est ce qui peut vous faire
penser une chose pareille mumbai
peut-être entre femmes je veux bien vous
le dire il ya belle lurette que la chine
ne me fait plus penser le mur du çon
d'accord
quand même ça marche et encore mais
alors depuis quelques temps plus rien
reloaded ont sans doute que monsieur
achille des influences astrales qui le
privait momentanément de ses moyens mais
des besoins des influences mis ça sur
mon mais croyez-moi le shérif n'a rien à
voir là dedans ça détrompez vous les
astres guide notre destinée concevez
vous donnez vous allez voir quel est
votre site capricorne ramassant
symbolisme et celui de nature enfermés
mais réfléchi patiente est d'accord
d'accord on a pas mal à écouter je ne
suis pas venu ici pour vous fassiez une
rose quoi passer alors que cherchez vous
suivent union si vous précis fait tout
il faudrait prendre face à nantes parce
que ça m'a réussi la dernière fois du
tout alors non fait entrer madame c'est
libre vous voyez bien vous permettez
genre oui merci
[Rires]
je ne vous dérange pas non vous attardez
monsieur vigneault oui sa secrétaire et
partie de chercher moi aussi je suis
venu pour le voir oui je veux dire
compagnie en attendant qu'ils n'arrivent
si vous le permettez l'ambré vous
connaissez bien monsieur lignon nom et
vous plutôt enfin plutôt bien oui vous
travaillez dans le bâtiment
le bâtiment mais enfin non je vous dire
vous travailler ici dans la maison je
suis enfin c'est à dire que je travaille
pour la maison oui mais
non à l'extérieur à des marcheuses
visiteuse en représentante
non moi je m'en fous moi mon but
chargé d'affaires des affaires un peu
spécial
je suis une sorte de deux chargés de
mission à et quel genre de mission chez
mabrouka qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est une masse tout si vous préférez
mabrouk à seynod arabe à vos intérêts
alors là pas du tout de suite plus tôt
je suis une empreinte plus tôt
et en plus je porte chance ah bon et
acquis à tout ce qui touche aux alors
moi si je voudrais bien entendu et oui
vous vous permettez je vous en prie m'en
vais parce que laurent en ce moment j'en
ai bien besoin du fait de vous gêner
moment-là la femme et moi mais pas comme
ça mais qu'elle faisait maintenant tout
de même pas il faut un contact comprenez
vous il faut le toucher là pour vous
tenez vous allez voir rapprochez-vous la
voilà maintenant prenez moi la main du
carrément n'ayez pas peur les îles à
alors
[Rires]
tutoyant il faut rester longtemps comme
ça bah ça ça dépend des cas vous ne
sentez rien ici à quoi je fatigue
à part ça rien du tout on n'a jamais
rien mais ça c'est bien possible parce
que je vous expliquais jusqu'à présent
j'en ai fait profiter surtout les hommes
du temps à les regarder touchant comme
ça et ça marche
ah bah enfin c'est à dire que plus les
rapports sont intimes plus les chances
de réussite sont grandes
je commence à vous oui naturellement
vous vous êtes payés pour ça faut bien
vivre
ben voyons la jambe du tout à fait
compris
mais dites moi vous travaillez pour
monsieur vigneault exclusivement pour
mon tonton oui parce que c'est votre
oncle par dessus de marché mais
l'épreuve remporte mon tonton c'est le
nom que je lui donne si vous préférez
cch au briquet
et de temps en temps vous ne faites pas
bien que petit extra alors uniquement
quand on tombe elle demain luis almeria
oui oh oui tenait en ce moment par
exemple oui bon et j'aime autant vous
dire que c'est pas tout post areva n'est
dans cette ardeur de tonton ce mot
pardon
je veux dire c'est un drôle de coco
votre toute la broussaille mg comprimé
en tentant un verbiage entier savait
seulement voilà c'est un maniaque de
l'astrologie et de l'inexpliqué ouais
alors tous explique van est et vous là
qu'est ce qui vous amène à moi c'est
très personnel ah oui c'est une affaire
de famille
ah ben j'espère que c'est pas grave non
mais ce que j'ai à lévis on va pas lui
faire tellement plaisir croyez moi est
la pauvre tantôt décidément c'est sa
journée un mois qu'il eut annoncé mon
départ un moule qui tombe
oui ça alors figurez vous que j'ai
rencontré un type formidable
un américain pas 30 juniors qui
s'appelle kim emmène avec lui il va
monter pour moi mais un grand show au
casino international djamel la menara
man c'est loin s'amuser c'est en arabie
saoudite ouvrir au bas l'abba sera la
vedette de larve mois avait pas ce que
vous dansez aussi mais tout madame tout
je chante je dors enfin là bas je
représenterai la tati femmes de parler
tarifs
à fribourg
là quelque chose comme ça ça va être
formidable as a toujours été mon rêve
oui vous avez intérêt à toucher tous les
spectateurs pour que ça marche
pas eu cette chance alors sanaa
changeman avoir besoin pour faire avaler
ça à mon tonton
d'autant plus que figurez-vous qu'en ce
moment il a descendu avec son frère avec
son frère à il a un frère oui mais vous
pouvez pas le connaître sa frères astral
ainsi raconté mme houle alors ça
m'intéresse pas
comment ça vous intéresse figurez vous
allez voir vous allez qui s'est
découvert fumée des incendies
un gros ipod touch namur je joue tout à
l'heure vous allez voir
achille maman pour lui c'est le krach en
question achille va mon boulanger jean
louis et ben ils profitent un peu trop
de la situation mais c'est comme je vous
le dis et pourtant même en tentant mais
c'est mieux en quatorze pour lui faire
plaisir non non non mais écoutez ça
j'étudie la bombarde et directeur d'une
de enfin je ne sais trop quoi l'un
pensons-y lui a fait gagner un
appartement à une tombola bidon les
bidons non mais dit il a pas arrêté là
ces gentillesses quand même vous trouvez
que c'est pas suffisant
je parie que c'est pour lui que vous
faites un extra avant ce moment et vous
avez gagné à la can
rabbit
rappaz
et quelle extra mais si vous saviez mais
c'est un type incroyable
super ils pensent qu'à ça catoire
thumesnil amellou bébé mais c'est que ça
n'arrête pas c'est une oeuvre et
mitraillettes
il a exclu des trucs grecque
je connaissais même fort et pour toi je
jure que j'en connais à salades crûs
madame juin la table areva ta mère je
fais confiance à mes c'est que sur les
rotules heureusement pour toi mis le
holà réagi à la merci
toujours porté chance aux vuvuzelas voir
j'ai bien fait de vous toucher
j'ai roulé d éducation mais j'en
demandais pas tant qu'elle allait pas
cette question là où votre espèce de
grand froid
mais de toute façon j'adore service
commandé j'ai fait pour lui porter
chance
oui moi j'aurais préféré qu'ils
s'amusent avec un trèfle à quatre
feuilles mêmes effets on comprend
maintenant pourquoi celle avait
tellement de tendresse hors terre
[Applaudissements]
mais alors qu'il essayait
d'établissements spécialisés pas exercer
mon service ouattara les gens des
maisons pour petit étriqué de m'insulter
puisque je pars musiciens pas mes
regrets
la photo
tournant dans la vie dure à 17 ans
sans rire
m
attention
je pars je ne fais pas mon contrat je
m'en vais regarde moi viens tu as devant
toi la future coqueluche de l'arabie
saoudite et je bats pour le moyen-orient
on va là-bas je trouverais la tête
[Applaudissements]
le sentier
j'aimais une sorcière l'avait jamais bon
je suis prêt mais sûrement j'ai vécu
avec elle j'ai fréquenté je sais mais
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous mettre
dans des états pareils je me sens si
seul je n'ai plus personne au nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai nous est plein vous avez
toujours été là donnez moi vos mains que
je sente un peu de chaleur humaine et
c'est ma vous embrasser si vous aimez ça
moi j'y suis pas hostile
[Musique]
voir
qu'est ce que vous sentez de ça rien
mais c'est méditation de thaïs il ment
voûte c'est mon parfum préféré c'est la
première fois que vous en a percé rejet
c'est la première fois que j'ai
l'occasion de vous sentir
vous pouviez pas me sentir c'est la
première fois que je vous vois de cyprès
et vous voyez tous les ou me semble que
je vous vois ce soir pour la première
fois qu'est ce qui vous me trouvez des
spéciales gentil je ne sais pas
peut-être parce que je vous ai prise
dans mes bras d'amma vous savez pour moi
c'était la première fois parce que
personne mon dieu quelle injustice
les hommes ne vous ont pas fait latine
ont jamais pour dire que je leur en ai
pas laisser non mais pourquoi avec la
vie que vous m'avez fait mais c'est moi
vous regardez celle de lui vous êtes
très désirable
quand je pense que j'ai vécu vingt en
bray dunes secrétaire et que je découvre
une femme infiniment apetissant et vous
êtes leur mère non je suis gourmand au
madeleine
ça fait 20 ans que je vous aime
mais pourquoi n'en avoir jamais parlé
vous l'avez pas demandé il faut les
ouvrir les yeux mais j'essayais 20 x 20
ans mais sans résultat j'y pense depuis
vingt ans tous ne réussissant que je le
mérite
c'est à vous que je le dois ma véritable
mabrouka c'est vous malheur aux
madeleine nom de l'autre côté parce que
tu côté là c'est pas ma main
oui
j'ai pas là dit elle vous viendra vite
vous verrez vous serez le premier
poisson de ma vie quelle coïncidence moi
aussi nous sommes les deux vierges mais
je vous croyais du signe du poisson ne
le faisait pas allusion aux audi ac l'ex
elle ne faisait pas allusion aux médias
qu elle ne faisait pas eu l'heur
veilleux madeleine dans mes bras
présence la fiancée confiant sûr mais
plus que cette blague comment tu pas une
blague frédéric tampère t'expliquera je
cherchais je crois je vois je sais je
suis désabusé hindous frémissement
m'agiter me parcourt un amour a prévu me
réchauffe le coeur je vois que le destin
ne m'abandonne pas et c'est pour qu'on
aille âge avant de parler de mon mariage
parlant du tien tu es ce que tu fais le
week end prochain
rien bon parfum je t'emmène jéléva
mobile os je suis désolé je suis pas
libre c'est une chasse en sologne
tchéquie jeu monsieur py l'état comme on
l'a fait depuis l'ata monsieur py l'état
a même papa tu as oublié un garçon une
fille qu'il est un mignon mignon pis
l'état rencontre colossal
comment elle a un écho mi-mars middle a
pas de menton ah oui mais tout s'arrange
avec la chirurgie esthétique
si les manques quelque chose on rajoute
elle en a trop on coupe quel est
l'imbécile qui tend à douter ça si tu
prends tout ce qu'on me dit alors on
oublie cette affreuse puis l'étape
deuxièmement que les tuent les travaux
du professeur albert est professeur qui
tu ne connais pas le professeur albrecht
un psychiatre berlinois milla frey
ah bah c'est moi qui tendait parler tu
m'as trompé tu m'as perdais ma gueule à
tout révéler madame matudi madeleine
tattoo duplication des jumeaux désastre
mais bien de l'union des enfants issus
des jumeaux désastre tu es poussera même
maman poule hausse oui mais est
légèrement tu la connais non mais elle
peut pas écrire que la boiteuse buts à 2
j'ai mon mot à dire rien à dire on m'a
vierge pense à ton l'enfant et fait que
nadine va mollo ce ne soit pas un monde
à l'école je vous présente natif samoa
les rallyes sans merci
malvoisin je vous en prie mettez-vous là
là je suis à vous dans l'instant la
tourterelle les cils ou quelques
instants que je pense au bonheur de ses
enfants avant de songer reviendrait
pouvoir tout à l'heure parce que j'ai
une surprise pour au cannet tel hawwa
les plus peureux mademoiselle je
m'appelle alexandre avignon et voici mon
fils frédéric
bonjour messieurs bonjour messieurs jean
mademoiselle mew ça prend du bon jour
mademoiselle génération mawazine nous
avons consulté des astres notre bonheur
est entre vos mains
c'est pourquoi je vous demande l'une
d'entre elles pour monfils fédérer qui
s'y pressent monsieur je ne le connais
pas justement que je vous offre la
meilleure manière de le connaître c'est
à dire de l'épouser il vous plait ainsi
tous les bornes on est passé où les
bleus pensent bouquet
qu'est ce que tu penses de mademoiselle
banon je préfère me moser qui l'état où
tu es fou regarde ses cheveux ses plans
des entreprises sont à vous permettez
whip it yens contre 800 postes à faire
les couilles d'extenso brunir à 19 ans
c'est merveilleux noël se fera en garde
de ne plus parler mais potel renault
fait huit morts aux samoa blanche aux
ateliers des enfants il ya un test bien
simple qui peut déchaîner en vous
l'amour le plus pur
embrassez vous mes enfants longuement
profondément comme roméo et juliette
daphnis et chloé pelléas et mélisande
castor et pollux
[Applaudissements]
non alors non non c'est ta photo dc il
sait pas y faire
regarde copé alors tu ne demandes de
noms ça fait plaisir avec des autres au
service ça mentionne tout reviendra pas
sur sa décision jamais tu me jure géant
la carte du ciel haïtien pour cela
retrouver
j'ai trouvé la clé de nombreux lot duels
et le 7 septembre aux huiles et juste
les grecs et bien dans mon calendrier
orthodoxe mon 7 septembre à moi tombe le
21 octobre
comment du lepa monfreid non c'est pas
possible
40 à viège suite la balance et du viol
qui s'abattent en mai pour faire il va
les regretter donnons aux gens de venir
c'est dur d'être débarrassé toi à l'eau
dont je préfère le roi va remonter sur
ses poutrelles moi tu vois ce que je
vois mais qu'est ce que tu suis d'abord
par frédéric a quelque chose à te dire
oui monsieur j'ai l'honneur de vous
noyer d'histoire ancienne à voir tous
les jurés sont à coeur du sujet alors si
on peut même plus durer comme ça dessus
de la cave à celle d'une bête mais il
faut faire le bonheur de frédéric je ne
serions rien avoir fusé ma petite
tourterelles mais j'en vois comme un
pigeonnier combat de les combattre on
fait des jeux par tonne a tué des corps
pour ce mariage nous sommes d'accord
marchand c'est un très bon parti voilà
voilà je mets plus deux frères c'était
tellement heureux d'avoir enfin un frère
même astral à ma surprise alex ans que
cela j'ai un frère astral née le même
jour que moi là d'abord talonneur du bo
lui écrire tout de suite répondu m'a
téléphoné à bien attendant son coup de
téléphone
voilà quelle coïncidence
on se croirait au t1 ce soir à l'eau
oui c'est toi mon frère oui j'ai dit au
revoir à tous son frère oui mon maître
certainement me m tu veux je viens de
chez toi tu mens votre aventure qu'est
ce que c'est comme voiture une deux
chevaux bon j'arrive je viens être pas
femmes du verrat les pulpeuses à demain
mon frère à demain mais mon frère le
guinness se mettre nu aux icônes
[Applaudissements]
j'invite monsieur la pièce nous avons eu
la joie et l'honneur de représenter
devant vous est de messieurs bricaire et
la sec
[Applaudissements]
dans un décor de roger hart
des costumes de donald cardwell
[Applaudissements]
avec
catherine lecoq
[Applaudissements]
ym you brega
arlette didier
christiane muller
[Applaudissements]
jacques bas rhin
et claude gensac
[Applaudissements]
une mise en scène de robert manuel
oui
[Musique]